right another week another day where
we're like hey
he's still alive alive is a very loose
term he's weakened at Patty's at this
point gonna give you a spoiler warning
because we're gonna talk about some
spoiler-ish things again as every
episode where I talk about an episode of
a show not gonna be a play-by-play we're
going to talk about some things that
stood out to me you've been warned so
we're gonna talk about some deaths and
some awkward Thanksgiving dinner so this
episode I think it was a six year time
Jump which is funny because I'm like six
year time job all right funny how that
rule of contrast Works six years would
have been crazy if 10 years hadn't
already happened now it's like oh six
it's not ten it's whatever after six
years these kids come face to face with
their Uncle whose eyeball they slashed
out the new Twitter shift incest power
couple returned to King's Landing after
six years apparently the sea snake's
just gone possibly dead this is where
those time gaps it's quite often I have
that feeling of there could have been an
episode in there instead we're reunited
after six years he's gone possibly dead
so now it's like okay who gets that
Throne I mean it's a family issue an
issue of succession tradition a very
important issue the kind of issue
someone's just gonna
lose their head over he got the MK9
though it was like right there above the
tongue I'll come back to that in a
second I'm not gonna I'm not just gonna
leave you there with it I did like with
renera the reality of the throne is
starting to come into Focus the
fantasies kind of melting away I kind of
got that feeling at a point anyway it's
easy to be like oh sweet I'm gonna get
that thrown you know my dad's dead it's
not like I want that to happen but when
the throne is that far away but still a
promised thing to you it's easy to be
like oh that'd be cool then when the
king is literally physically not half
the man he used to be it seems much
closer and it's like that's that is
heavy I like seeing Damon and viserys
moments too those have become some of my
favorite things to see because they've
always just kind of been
there's a brotherly love there but right
it's gone wrong a few times and in these
Eight Episodes we've seen about 30 years
of that tension and then it's like okay
who gets to see snakes thrown these kids
are promised to these kids and this
dude's like dude those aren't those are
not Valerian kids I feel bad for the
kids in these situations because the
kids know too they're like okay I I know
obviously we're not Valerian but again
we didn't ask to be alive would you we
we're sentients and we have life and
we're just kind of in the middle of this
[ __ ] I come from a divorced family
my heart always bleeds for the kids and
when the dude was like you know what
everyone's thinking it I'm going to say
it
those are not Valerian her kids are
bastards I was like well so he's the one
gonna die in this
oh that's well that just happened my
favorite part of this episode for many
reasons was the awkward family dinner it
kind of shows that old adage How does it
go you can trap more bees with honey
than vinegar well until
until the king leaves and then the [ __ ]
kinda hits the fan but for that moment
Rainier has given out compliments to the
Queen the Queen's giving compliments to
renera probably because she's like your
kids are better behaved than my kids my
kids are well they're just dicks
what can I say aegon's that total
burnout still lives with his parents
he's just douching around but this is
when I was like I think King viserys was
gonna die I thought he was gonna die at
the dinner table because everyone's
being nice and everyone's kumbayaing and
it's kind of like that awkward
Thanksgiving dinner of a family that
just hates each other and it's almost
like all right what are you thankful for
say something nice about someone at the
table the king viserys it looked like he
was feeling good like I'm I'm seeing my
family mend I'm gonna go to bed thank
you take me back then there's [ __ ] talk
and the fights start breaking out I give
it to Damon though Damon just stepped in
between he was like unless you slept
through this episode I'm the one who
takes head and doesn't give it keep
walking oh I was kind of expecting a red
dinner like all the kids with dark hair
dead didn't happen but was expecting it
what can I say I guess I like the
awkward dinner because that's what I've
been conditioned to watch the show for
family drama that's why we're clocking
in you really do get the feeling that
King viserys is the glue holding all of
this together someone who doesn't watch
the end of the episode next week on
House of the Dragon thing all I can say
is it looks like he might have died at
the end of this episode but in a couple
other episodes it looked like he died at
the end of those episodes but yeah he
looks pretty dead yeah he was all super
Stoned on milk of the poppy and he was
like oh the vision and aegon and the Sun
that was promised the king that was
promised the Queen's like what our super
burnout dick bag son is some sort of
Prophecy read you loud and clear this
was the Calm before the storm that
dinner the foreshadowing of all that's
coming watch next week's like after the
30-year time Jump wow that war was crazy
man it's like that's the end of my
thoughts
I don't know how to segue into the end
of the episode oh my gosh I'm so off
today we all have those days they happen
all right so House of the Dragon episode
8 have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's the most awkward
family dinner you've ever seen you can
say yours that's fine but if you name
entertainment it's it's more relatable
for the folks whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
[Music]